in my time for using the internet I have
found that everybody loves kinetics and
I want to be hip and cool so I'm gonna
try and make DIY kinetics and kinetics
and this stuff right here this is a
store-bought version that like hopefully
satisfying it's not wet it's not dry I
think three really popular recipes that
I am going to make them then compare
them to the store bought version and
have a very vigorous round of testing
and experimentation which pretty much
means I'm going to play with kinetics
and for like an hour
recipe number one you need sand school
glue food coloring glitter and detergent
sounds like a recipe for students
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so it's kind of kinetic this
next recipe is from a mom blog and lungs
never lies so this is totally gonna work
you need water
fourth dark in dish soap and obviously
[Music]
this one's really good it smells great
actually it smells way better than the
real kinetic sand that stuff smells a
little funky this last one is the most
viral it's got like 3 million meters so
it's got to work right
[Music]
oh my god I hate this texture so much oh
my god
[Music]
okay yeah some preliminary reactions on
our final recipe fix-ups eight is a
million tiny little pieces of you with
some particles of sand pushed into them
yes definitely the worst so far but I
won't make any official conclusions
until we put it through the vigorous
scientific professional testing let's
make some sand castles oh my goodness
Wow I'm so impressed with myself alright
it is time for our final conclusion can
you make DIY kinetic sand and if so
which recipe is the best we have put
these through some pretty rigorous
testing the first recipe was quite a
surprise we have a very nice piece of
architecture here and it has glitter so
extra points for the glitter now our
second recipe the Mom Blog recipe look
at that same vessel that is pristine
everything you already have in your
house and I'd say it's the closest to
the store bought version okay that one
sucks just as much as I thought it would
suck so way to go for meeting my
expectations and of course the store
bought version the least messy of all of
them if you're looking for something
that won't stick to your hands at all
the store bought version is great yeah
it's really cool but it also costs $20
and this probably cost me like five you
get way more bang for your buck with the
mom's law exam I would say the winner of
this di tribe is
[Music]
it is 10:30 at night and we walked into
Ashley just playing with sand whatever
here